now let's get to last night's emotional
premiere of John Wick chapter four the
cast hitting the red carpet three days
after the sudden loss of their beloved
co-star Lance Reddick
[Music]
Lance was is a very
beautiful person and a special artist we
lost our brother we lost our brother
he's the goodness of this movie yeah of
this franchise really the cast wore blue
ribbons to honor Lance the film out
Friday is also dedicated to him the 60
year old is said to have died of natural
causes last Friday and I talked with him
just two weeks earlier about his
motivation my wife with my ambition you
and I left a good life behind a long
time ago my friend you know the audience
is there the love for John Wick is there
but it takes a little bit more for every
film do you have more in you for the
franchise
you know when you love something you
always have a little bit more he's as
cool as a Hawaiian Breeze like his name
also on the carpet Derek Huff big news
out of the Dancing with the Stars World
sister's back and we're really really
excited to see her in Alfonso do their
thing and their chemistry their energy
they could probably do a full dance
routine together don't you think they
should they probably will
foreign